it's the most compelling thing about
people that have reached your stature in
any business is when they talk about the
difficulties of connecting early on and
you talk about going to Japan for the
first time we thought that we'd be an
overnight sensation though we just
thought we went and and we went to the
we were young men there and you know
slim physique and everything and we went
and we bought Japanese schoolboy outfits
which are Nehru jackets you know with no
collar yeah and we thought we looked
exactly like the Beatles at Shea Stadium
we actually look like rather strange
European people wearing Japanese
schoolboy outfit we hired a flatbed
truck and decided that we would make an
impression about driving down the Ginza
playing rock and rollin driving through
Times Square with the music bouncing off
all the buildings I mean this is it but
either one of two things will happen
either will be an overnight sensation
our record will crash into the charts or
we'll be arrested and deported and will
that'll make us famous right sure and
they just came along and they gave a
ticket to the guy for over loading the
trucks tiny little picture about this
big on the paper and and we only have a
picture of it no one cares people are
just walking by I'm there with a box of
records that they're giving us and I'm
trying to give them to people as they go
by while the band plays and I ended up
just having to frisbee them and there's
people even catch the records they were
just ducking you injured people I did
and yeah I'm still paying off the
lawsuit